the Joe Rogan experience so you you like
these kind of far out there ideas how do
you like this idea there is a cut
there's a group of people that say that
dragons were real and I'll explain so it
around the same time period so to speak
and I'm not one of these people so I'm
probably gonna get the details wrong
Matthew McConaughey mover yeah seriously
but so around the same time period in
you know China South America Africa all
these different Rome all these places
images depicted people fighting dragons
right and every every dragon was
slightly different but it was all a
giant scaly animal that could fly so
when you take when you break that down
you think about the fact that large
birds had a hard time being fossilized
because their bones are so porous right
so because bones there have like hollow
wishbones they break down very easily
and they don't fossilize so the the the
group that says this basically they're
they're saying the evidence is the
reason there's no fossils of dragons is
because they had bird bones and they
were actually very delicate animals but
a handful of these more small a small
population of these giant lip flying
lizards existed and basically
encompassed all these different
countries where they all depicted
fighting dragons in their own way and
they were all killed off by you know
knights or whatever it is and then
didn't fossilize so it's like the
science is saying that if there were
lizards big enough to fly around and eat
people they didn't have bones that could
fossilize so it'd be like an eagle right
and so and that's why you know that's
why all these human populations around
the world have depictions of them
because they did actually exist now are
there any stories of dragons like
written like in the times of people that
they have actually had the written word
or is it just depictions i don't know
not my field that i interesting because
like are these depictions like ancient
accounts told by generation after
generally passed so i think i don't know
i don't know anything about dragons or
whether it's real but i think it's
interesting to think oh well the science
supports that if there were flying
lizards their bones wouldn't have
fossilized and these have been passed
down stories that have been exaggerated
and passed down from generation to
generation and some of them breathe fire
but some of them don't pick up on
which culture it was significant - I
wonder if what the fire with the fire
supposed to represent or they just
people are full of [ __ ] probably that
one yeah probably made it sound even
cooler yeah exactly
do you think that do you hold any weight
do you think that holds any way no
actually dragon I mean we know there
were large flying lizards during the
times the dinosaurs right the only
weight that it could possibly hold is
that like a few of those somehow
survived much later than we previously
thought but I do I think that there were
at dragons attacking human beings and
civilizations now I don't but it's still
interesting it's so much cooler if there
were right the fact that we know that
pterodactyls did exist that's cool right
would be rate way cores that they
existed with people right 2,000 years
ago why is that so much cooler now it's
like I would be I would I mean people
would dedicate giant chunks of their
life trying to find out if pterodactyls
did coexist with human beings at one
time I really would absolutely many of
you but there was a hundred-foot
pterodactyl snatching kids be terrifying
Oh God would you know about the the MOA
eagle yeah yeah the hasta hasta called
MOA you go because they used to Tecmo
these were that big
no but they did supposedly snatch Maori
children yeah but when I googled it I
remember I think the large ones were
like forty pounds or something like that
I don't think they were that but all it
is yeah an eagle is really light right
but their wingspan enormous yeah I mean
they're they have incredible power but
you don't see an eagle snatch a salmon
with its claws and fly away with this
10-pound salmon right and it's climbing
that's insane it is because that salmon
probably weighs more than it right right
birds are weird right they sit on you
like oh you're not really heavy no they
don't weigh anything and again that goes
back to that whole hollow bone type
thing right that's why chickens are
strange because they're fat yeah they
weigh a lot like you pick up a chicken
oh you fat [ __ ] but bird like a hawk of
a fairly light yeah for what it is yeah
yeah I think was the biggest haast eagle
how big was the hosta go but they were
hunted by people right because they they
posed a threat
because people hunted the MOA to
extinction that giant bird that named
her that the hasti will primarily preyed
on and so the twofold kind of made them
collapse yeah
large gigantic ancient things 8 and 1/2
C wingspan for females typically eight
and a half feet possibly up to ten in a
few cases why female I'm trying to talk
just the first thing I see yeah and what
about the big do males 25 pounds females
31 pounds
Oh females largest female could have
been 36 pounds and mass yeah but still
it big but a 10-foot wingspan is getting
huge Oh huge yeah I mean you know talons
you they've got it I don't know but they
had to have been enormous yes
flying knives yeah well you've seen the
videos that the the Mongols use where
they they train Golden Eagles to kill
wolves mhm yeah crazy son believe they
[ __ ] up wolves like yeah way smaller
than a wall oh yeah the wolf has zero
chance right they swoop down and grab a
wolf by the back of the neck and just
[ __ ] them up isn't it crazy trying to
get away and they just killing them and
I believe maybe it's not Mongolian
culture but one of those you know Falk
Andry cultures you have to like as a
teenage boy or something like that
you're right of passage is to go climb
the cliff and take the check out of the
nest and it's like this crazy process
where you know a number of kids died
trying to get to the Eagle chick and the
ones that come back that's their bird
for however long the bird lives or I
don't really know the hook process right
now the avatar isn't that nuts
right yeah that's bananas I'm gonna
steal the chick from the nest and raise
it uh-huh figured that out who figured
out you're gonna train a [ __ ] raptor
I don't know like how weird are people
yeah they figure these things out and
someone was the first you know I mean
someone was like I'm gonna go get that
baby bird I'm gonna you know what he
probably did you probably got high off
that honey climb and that's here I mean
it hit me a [ __ ] bird bird do all the
hunting that's like you're crazy man oh
you can't have a bird do the hunt
[Applause]